With a big surprise credits scene and an ingenious
twist, the Enola Holmes sequel is loaded with
hidden clues and bonus Sherlock easter eggs.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan,
and in this video I'm explaining why we could
well be getting a new Sherlock spin-off plus
all the little details I spotted in
the movie you might have missed.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
By the end of the movie, Enola exposes the
conspiracy that Mr Lyon and Lord McIntyre,
have been covering up the deaths of workers
at the match factory from white phosphorus
poisoning, and blaming it on typhus.
However, there was a clue to what was really
going on very early in the film when a girl with a
disfigured jaw was turned away from the factory.
This was a real-life condition that afflicted
workers in the matchstick industry at the
time and was known as "phossy jaw".
And there's another early clue to
this conspiracy when Enola breaks
into Mr Lyon's office and discovers a box of
non-toxic red matches rather than the white
matches being made on the factory floor.
So, it looks like he wasn't willing to even
risk using the new white matches himself, but he'd
let his workers breathe in their fumes all day.
Also, notice how the original red matchbox sold
for two pennies, whereas the white matches sell
for half the price, a big hint to how much cheaper
the white phosphorus really was and also to the
motivation behind Lyon’s heartless behaviour.
Matches!
Only a penny a box.
The next big twist comes
when we discover that McIntyre's secretary
Miss Troy is Sherlock's nemesis Moriarty.
If you spotted the Moriarty clue when she
revealed her full name to Enola at the ball,
give yourself a pat on the back...
Mira Troy, private secretary to
Lord McIntyre.
But what you might have missed was
an even sneakier clue earlier on, when Sherlock
reveals a critical piece of information about the
mastermind behind the string of unauthorised
money transfers he's been investigating.
A week before the first transfer,
there was a break-in at the Treasury
office by a man in a taper crown hat.
Notice that the first time we see Miss Troy,
she's the only person wearing a tapered crown hat
– that means it narrows as it
goes up
– whereas
the other characters' hats are untapered
– in other words, their hats go up straight.
Talk about keeping Moriarty's
identity under her hat!
If you turned the movie off as soon
as the credits began, you'll have
missed a crucial bonus mid-credits scene!
In the scene, Sherlock is puffing on his pipe,
ready to meet his sister for their
4pm Thursday appointment, but she's
arranged for John Watson to turn up instead.
Sherlock had told Enola she could be his flatmate,
but she turned down his offer in order to keep
working independently of her famous brother.
So, instead she told Dr Watson that
Sherlock was looking for a flatmate,
because remember she said to her brother
she didn't think he should be alone so much
No one should be alone all the time.
A friend would do you well.
It looks like this could be
setting up a potential spin-off
movie or series for Henry Cavill's Sherlock.
I know a lot of fans would like to see this,
and it could be a good way for both Millie Bobby
Brown and Cavill to get plenty of room to focus
on their own characters in separate movies,
while also crossing paths from time to time.
Let me know what you think in
the comments below and leave a
thumbs-up if you'd like to see this happen!
And with Sherlock's increased screentime in the
sequel, we get even more Sherlock easter eggs.
The film's production team really went to town
designing the look and feel of 221B Baker Street.
They wanted to show how this Sherlock is
"a slightly obsessive collector" and his
untidy bachelor's pad is full of "skeletons
of rare beasts, geological specimens, fossils,
insects, microscopes and magnifying glasses."
There's also a little tortoise figure on
Sherlock's floor holding down some papers
which feels like a nod to Sherlock's turtle Clyde
in the CBS series Elementary and perhaps also to
this little moment from the TV show.
I'm pretty sure you shouldn't
use Clyde as a paperweight.
Sherlock's famous violin is also
prominently featured in the room and he uses it
briefly when he plays the tune to a clue Enola
found on Mae's body.
The famous fiddle.
And there's an amusing little interplay between
Lestrade and Sherlock when he comes across
Sherlock's pipe.
Take it.
Take it?
I can't.
[chuckles]
Perhaps I can.
The iconic pipe was teased in the first film
with this picture of him puffing on it.
This is actually a 1891 sketch published in "The
Man With The Twisted Lip", with Henry Cavill's
face overlaid on the original image.
At the beginning of the movie, Enola is
struggling at her newly-opened detective agency,
while her brother's fame continues to rise.
Read all about it!
Sherlock Holmes and
the case of the Brixton corpse.
This is a shout-out to the very
first Sherlock Holmes book "A Study in Scarlet"
where he investigates a murder in Brixton.
Enola's potential clients won't take her
seriously because of her gender and age.
And she can't even get her due credit for
the case she solved in the first movie.
The Tewkesbury case?
Well, that was Sherlock Holmes.
That was Sherlock.
Sherlock.
Sherlock Holmes, wasn't it?
She's even mistaken for a secretary at one point,
which is an easter egg to the original Enola
Holmes novels where she had to masquerade as a
secretary in order to pursue her vocation.
When Bessie comes to Enola for help to
investigate her missing sister, she
shows Enola's newspaper ad for her
detective agency: "Missing persons found".
This is a hat-tip to how in the books Enola
refers to herself as a "Scientific Perditorian",
a title she made-up from the Latin word "perditus"
meaning "lost" or as Enola puts it…
And I am a finder of lost souls.
By the way, the little toy that Enola dropped
just before Bessie came into the agency,
is Dash, Enola's pet toy from the first
movie, which Sherlock brought to her when
she was stuck at finishing school,
and which she also left as a clue to
Sherlock at the very end of the first film.
You had a pine cone wrapped in wool, dragged it
with you wherever you went, calling it Dash.
Hidden in the newspapers that keep popping up
are some great secret jokes and details.
When Enola talks about teaching a dog to sit,
the movie cuts to an advert for Dr
Pavlov's Patented Pooch Persuader,
Approved by Socks the Wonder Dog.
This is an amusing reference to physiologist Ivan
Pavlov's discovery that he could condition dogs
to salivate at the sound of a bell, by ringing a
bell whenever they were shown a plate of food.
After a while, the dogs associated the bell
sound with food and salivated even
if they weren't brought any food.
These principles of classical conditioning
are popularly known as Pavlov's dog.
[barking]
By the way, if you pause here,
you'll see that Socks the Wonder Dog is
actually a regular performer at the Paragon
Theatre where Sarah and Mae used to work.
And if you pause the film right at this point, you
can also spot an advert for a crazy contraption
called an "Electropathic Belt" which promises
to cure "weak and languid feelings", "nervousness
and rupture", "corpulence and general debility".
Amazingly this isn't a made-up joke for the
movie, but a real device that was sold in
Victorian London by the Medical Battery Company.
In fact, electric belts and other pseudo-medical
devices were widely promoted around
the time Enola Holmes is set,
and they were touted as being able to treat
a vast array of illnesses and conditions.
A huge exposé was later run in the Pall
Mall Gazette, the newspaper that features
in the movie, and which also had previously
run numerous ads for the very same belt.
And if you watch all the way
through the movie's fancy credits,
you'll find some more hidden in-jokes and
easter eggs for the filmmakers and crew.
There's an advert for "Brown & Brown
Fine Confectionary" with a photo of
Millie Bobby Brown and her dad Robert
Brown, both producers on the movie.
And "Springer's Silver Fountain Pens, Fine
Writing Implements for the Scholar and Scribe"
is a reference to Nancy Springer who wrote the
original "Enola Holmes Mysteries" book series.
There's an ad for Nuttgens' Silver Nitrate Studios
on the credit for Director of Photography, Giles
Nuttgens, appropriately enough given that silver
nitrate is a chemical used to make film stock.
And Millie Bobby Brown's sister Paige
gets a shout-out via "Browns Bookbinders",
which might also be a reference to how it
was Paige who originally proposed the idea
of Millie playing the part of Enola on screen
after she discovered the Enola Holmes books.
And if you'd like to discover the biggest changes
made from the Enola Holmes books for the movies,
and how they made Henry Cavill's Sherlock a lot
more sympathetic, tap here to watch that video or
follow the link in the video description.
So, what did you think of Enola Holmes 2?
And are you hyped up to see more of
Henry Cavill's Sherlock with Watson?
Let me know what you think below.
And if you enjoyed this don't forget
to leave a thumbs -up and hit that
subscribe button and notification
bell to get more videos just like this.
Thanks for enjoying this movie with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!